Have you ever wondered what it takes to make a change in your life? A real change. For many people, the simple idea of change is a stressor, and with the day-to-day demands of life, it can become overwhelming. In this episode, author and clinical psychologist Dr. Pamela Hayes discusses how she helps her own patients tackle their stressors and take that first step toward happiness. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology.
你是否曾经想过，要改变自己的生活需要什么？真正的改变。对许多人来说，改变这个简单的念头本身就是一种压力源，再加上日常生活的琐事，这可能会让人感到不知所措。在本期节目中，作家兼临床心理学家帕梅拉·海耶斯博士将讨论她如何帮助自己的患者应对压力，并迈出通往幸福的第一步。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》节目。
Dr. Pamela Hayes is a clinical psychologist practicing in Alaska. She is also the author of several books, including her latest, called Creating Well-Being, Four Steps to a Happier, Healthyer Life, which is published by the American Psychological Association. Dr. Hayes' research has included work with Vietnamese, Lao, and Cambodian people living in the United States and with Arab Muslim women living in North Africa. Since 2000, she has been providing psychotherapy to adults, children, couples, and families in the Kenai Peninsula area of Alaska. Welcome, Dr. Hayes. Thank you. Your book is called Four Steps to a Happy or Healthyer Life. Can you tell us briefly what those four steps are?
帕梅拉·海耶斯博士是一位在阿拉斯加执业的临床心理学家。她也是多本书的作者，包括由美国心理学会出版的最新著作《创造幸福：通往更快乐、更健康生活的四个步骤》。海耶斯博士的研究包括在美国生活的越南裔、老挝裔和柬埔寨裔人群，以及北非的阿拉伯穆斯林女性。自2000年以来，她一直在阿拉斯加基奈半岛地区为成人、儿童、夫妇和家庭提供心理治疗。欢迎您，海耶斯博士。谢谢。您的书名为《通往更快乐、更健康生活的四个步骤》。您能简要告诉我们这四个步骤是什么吗？
The first step is about getting inspired. I find that when people come to see me in my practice, they're usually pretty low. And even taking a very small step can just feel like a lot. When problems feel really overwhelming, it can just seem pointless to even take a small step. So the first thing I do is help people get inspired. I have a number of ways of doing that. One of the main ways is to help people begin to focus on what their core values are,
第一步是获得灵感。我发现当人们来我的诊所看我时，他们的状态通常很低落。即使是迈出非常小的一步，也会让人感觉负担沉重。当问题让人感到非常不知所措时，迈出哪怕一小步似乎都毫无意义。所以我做的第一件事就是帮助人们获得灵感。我有多种方法来实现这一点。其中主要的方法之一是帮助人们开始关注他们的核心价值观，
and then also what they enjoy doing and what builds them up. The second step is assessing the stress in your life, and that includes paying attention to your body's messages about how stress affects you. It also includes figuring out what are stressors in your life, and then from there, step three involves paying attention to your thinking, and how your thinking may be affecting your stress level and then beginning to change your thoughts so that you're not so distressed.
以及他们喜欢做什么，什么能让他们振作起来。第二步是评估你生活中的压力，这包括注意身体发出的关于压力如何影响你的信号。它还包括找出你生活中的压力源，然后从那里开始，第三步涉及关注你的思维，以及你的思维如何影响你的压力水平，然后开始改变你的想法，这样你就不会那么痛苦了。
The fourth step is moving into action, changing your behavior or changing some things in your environment. So just to quickly summarize, the first step is getting inspired. The second step is assessing your stress level and figuring out the stressors in your life. The third step is changing your thought patterns to help you decrease your stress,
第四步是付诸行动，改变你的行为或改变环境中的某些事物。简单总结一下，第一步是获得灵感。第二步是评估你的压力水平并找出生活中的压力源。第三步是改变你的思维模式以帮助你减轻压力，
and the fourth step is taking action. And talking about stress, you mentioned that it can create a significant disconnect between your body and mind, leaving you feeling run down, physically, mentally. How can mindfulness help? And, you know, first of all, tell us a little bit about what mindfulness is. Mindfulness basically means just paying attention to the present moment without judgment. And it's a simple idea, but it's a pretty powerful experience when you do it. One of the simplest ways to do it is to just quickly focus on your, well, I'll take the,
第四步是采取行动。说到压力，你提到它会在你的身心之间造成严重的脱节，让你在身体和精神上都感到疲惫。正念如何提供帮助？首先，请告诉我们什么是正念。正念基本上就是不加评判地关注当下。这是一个简单的想法，但当你实践它时，这是一种相当强大的体验。最简单的方法之一就是快速专注于你的，好吧，我把“快速”这个词去掉，就专注于你的呼吸。
word out quickly, just focus on your breath. And as you focus on your breath, notice the feeling of the air moving in through your nostrils as you breathe in, and then notice the feeling of the air moving out through your nostrils as you breathe out. And as you do that for even a few seconds, you start to notice that your body begins to calm itself a little bit. And as you go into this sort of more calming state and you begin to let go of the judgments, that constant sort of cognitive dialogue we have in our heart, and our body, you heads. It tends to open us up to the world. It opens us up to ourselves, helps us be more compassionate, and compassion feels much better than judgmentalism. It's a more enjoyable emotion
当你专注于呼吸时，注意吸气时空气流经鼻孔的感觉，然后注意呼气时空气流出鼻孔的感觉。当你这样做哪怕几秒钟时，你就会开始注意到你的身体开始自我平静下来。当你进入这种更平静的状态，并开始放下评判——那种我们在心中、身体里和头脑中不断进行的认知对话——时，它往往会让我们向世界敞开。它让我们向自己敞开，帮助我们变得更有同情心，而同情心比评判感感觉好得多。这是一种更令人愉悦的情绪，
to feel compassionate. It's easier. It also, mindfulness, when we're in this present moment, slows us down so we're less reactive to events that are occurring around us. We're able to act more thoughtfully in ways that are helpful than out of emotional. emotion in ways that may work against us. So, oh, the other way, too, is that it tends to open us up to more positive possibilities. We're not just focusing completely on the negative because when any of us get stressed, we tend to skew towards the negative. We tend to just see the negative.
感受同情心更容易。此外，当我们处于当下时，正念会让我们慢下来，从而减少对周围发生的事件的反应。我们能够更深思熟虑地采取有益的行动，而不是出于情绪化，因为情绪化有时会适得其反。哦，另一种方式是，它往往会让我们向更多的积极可能性敞开。我们不会只完全关注消极面，因为当我们感到压力时，我们往往会倾向于消极。我们往往只会看到消极的一面。
We forget about the positive and we don't even perceive it. But mindfulness brings us back from worrying about the future or fretting about the past to just what's here and now. and that helps us recognize, oh, okay, maybe there are some other possibilities for moving forward. You've been practicing for a while. What sort of stressors do you see clients dealing with these days? It seems as if everyone is so busy and they never have time to unwind. What do you tell people to do if they're feeling overwhelmed? You know, most of the time the kinds of things I work with people on are the same things that I hear clinicians
我们忘记了积极的一面，甚至无法察觉它。但正念把我们从对未来的担忧或对过去的烦恼中拉回到此时此刻。这有助于我们认识到，哦，好吧，也许还有其他前进的可能性。你已经执业一段时间了。你现在看到客户在处理什么样的压力源？似乎每个人都太忙了，从来没有时间放松。如果人们感到不知所措，你会告诉他们做什么？你知道，大多数时候，我与人们一起处理的事情，和我听到的其他临床医生
in other parts of the U.S. and working with people on. And I noticed one day in particular, I'd had about six people in a row, and every one of them was talking about the pain or anger or frustration or worry about a relationship. And I started thinking, was this just coincidence today? And so I decided to look back at my records for the last week and then for the last month. And it was amazing. Something like 98% of everybody I had seen, it had really been about a relationship. either a parent with a team that they didn't know what to do with
在美国其他地区与人们一起处理的事情是一样的。有一天我特别注意到，我连续接待了大约六个人，他们每个人都在谈论关于人际关系的痛苦、愤怒、沮丧或担忧。我开始想，这只是今天的巧合吗？所以我决定回顾一下过去一周甚至过去一个月的记录。这太令人惊讶了。我接待的每个人中，大约98%的人确实都是关于人际关系的。要么是父母与他们不知道该怎么办的青少年，
or a team that was really frustrated with relationships at school or somebody with a supervisor at work that was giving him a hard time and were feeling badly about or more often couples, someone going through a divorce or someone being pulled into an affair and feeling guilty. So I was really struck by this. And along the way I found this question, from the Dalai Lama that I think sort of summed it all up. It was, the greatest source of human suffering is disconnection from one another.
要么是一个对学校人际关系感到非常沮丧的青少年，或者是一个在工作中被主管刁难的人，他们对此感到难过，或者更常见的是夫妇，有人正在经历离婚，或者有人卷入婚外情并感到内疚。所以我对此印象深刻。在此过程中，我发现了达赖喇嘛提出的一个问题，我认为它总结了一切。他说，人类痛苦的最大根源是彼此之间的疏离。
And I think that is, well, it is something I come back to frequently, that when people feel disconnected from others, that brings us the biggest pain. So a lot of what I do is help people with that. The other piece I would say in sort of modern day today is that people are so overwhelmed with everything they have to do and everything they feel they have to do, believe they have to do, and social media and constant incoming stimuli from diverse sources, it can just feel overwhelming. And so that seems to be a more, I'd say more recent development that affects a lot of people. I think it's interesting this idea of thought traps, you know, this idea that we have to do something or we should do something
我认为这是，嗯，这是我经常回到的一个观点，当人们感到与他人疏离时，这会给我们带来最大的痛苦。所以我所做的很多工作就是帮助人们解决这个问题。我想说的现代社会的另一个方面是，人们被他们必须做的一切、他们觉得必须做的一切、他们相信必须做的一切，以及社交媒体和来自不同来源的持续输入信息所淹没，这让人感到不知所措。所以这似乎是一个更近期的发展，影响了很多人。我认为关于“思维陷阱”的想法很有趣，你知道，我们必须做某事或我们应该做某事，
and how that affects our motivations. You know, basically they just don't do it. So can you talk about thought traps and how they impact us? There are some real common ones that most of us engage in when we're under stress. One of the, well, and you just explain the idea. The idea of a thought stressor is something you tell yourself, you go over and over, or a particular interpretation you tend to make about someone's behavior or events around you
以及这如何影响我们的动机。你知道，基本上他们就是不做。那么你能谈谈思维陷阱以及它们如何影响我们吗？当我们处于压力之下时，我们大多数人都会陷入一些非常常见的陷阱。其中一个，嗯，你刚才解释了这个想法。思维压力源是你告诉自己的事情，你反复思考的事情，或者你倾向于对某人的行为或周围事件做出的某种解释，
that really bring you down. They make you feel much more stressful. There are certain things in life that just bring stress because we're humans. I mean, if you have a loss, someone you deeply care about, dies, or you go through a divorce, something like that. I mean, that's stressful, and there's a certain amount of that you can't take away if you did. You wouldn't be human. But there's another layer of it that we pile on ourselves with the, oh, what was me? Well, what if this happens?
这真的会让你情绪低落。它们会让你感到压力更大。生活中有些事情确实会带来压力，因为我们是人类。我的意思是，如果你经历了失去，你深爱的人去世了，或者你经历了离婚，诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，那是很有压力的，如果你经历了这些，你无法消除一定程度的压力。如果你能消除，你就不是人了。但还有另一层压力是我们自己强加给自己的，比如“我真可怜”、“如果发生这种情况怎么办？”
But, oh, no, what if that happens? And, oh, then maybe they really don't like me. And so I help people figure out what those things are that they're saying to themselves. And to give you an idea some of the really typical ones, what ifs are a big one, what ifs are about the future? What if this happens? But then what if that happens? But then, okay, what if this happens? If onlys are about the past, similarly.
“哦，不，如果发生那种情况怎么办？”“哦，也许他们真的不喜欢我。”所以我帮助人们找出他们对自己说的那些话。为了让你了解一些非常典型的例子，“如果……怎么办”是一个大问题，“如果……怎么办”是关于未来的。如果发生这种情况怎么办？但如果发生那种情况怎么办？但如果发生这种情况怎么办？“要是……就好了”是关于过去的，类似地。
But, oh, if only I hadn't said that. If only I hadn't done that. If only they hadn't done that or said that. It wouldn't have worked out. You know, so both of those, whether they're the what-ifs or if-onlys tend to just take us down. They tend to make us more stressed. And the more stressed we are, the less likely we are to take action to make change. There are a number of other ones, things like shoulds are a really common one.
“哦，要是当初我没说那句话就好了。”“要是当初我没做那件事就好了。”“要是他们没做那件事或没说那句话就好了。”事情就不会这样了。你知道，所以这两者，无论是“如果……怎么办”还是“要是……就好了”，往往只会让我们情绪低落。它们往往会让我们压力更大。我们压力越大，我们就越不可能采取行动做出改变。还有许多其他的陷阱，比如“应该”就是一个非常常见的陷阱。
When you say should to yourself, oh, I really should be losing weight, oh, I really should clean the house, I really should or have to or I must, there are sort of variations on it, they tend to increase anxiety, which then tends to decrease our motivation to do anything about it. If you change that to something that's a little gentler to, you know, I'd really like to clean the house today, but my teenager really needs me to take her to the doctor, and I can't do both, and I need to recognize that. You recognize there's still a problem the house needs cleaning,
当你对自己说“应该”时，比如“哦，我真的应该减肥了”、“哦，我真的应该打扫房子了”、“我真的应该”或“我必须”或“我一定要”，这些都是它的变体，它们往往会增加焦虑，进而降低我们采取行动的动力。如果你把它改成更温和一点的说法，比如“你知道，我今天真的很想打扫房子，但我女儿真的需要我带她去看医生，我无法两者兼顾，我需要认识到这一点。”你认识到房子仍然需要打扫，这是一个问题，
but you can't do it today. There's no point in beating yourself up about it. Thank you very much, Dr. Hayes. It was very interesting. Thanks for joining us. You're welcome. Thank you. To purchase Dr. Hay's book and to hear more podcasts, please visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology,
但你今天做不到。因为这件事而责备自己是没有意义的。非常感谢你，海耶斯博士。这非常有趣。感谢你加入我们。不客气。谢谢。如需购买海耶斯博士的书并收听更多播客，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》节目的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。
I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。